all right so very happy to have this
Omar come here so you tell us about our
series this is an extension of the
project that we just heard about before
the break and I will talk about some of
the more algebraic and structural
aspects that you run into trouble when
you try to extend this result so in
Clint stock if I had to sum it up in one
sentence it would say that you can't
lift lower bounds from matrix line to
lower bounds for tensor rank or Warren
band by using linear maps yeah this is a
reasonable summary of what chemists I
know tells so in this sense tensile rank
is a harder problem than matrix rank and
I don't want to say this in a formal
complexity theory notion just a just
that it's a harder problem you have to
do something not to build to get low
bounce pretends around here's a question
that I'm gonna ask is suppose somebody
told you how to get lower bonds for
three tensors
you then use it to get lower bounds for
four tensors there is some way of saying
well are three tensors necessarily
harder easier or just as hard as four
tensors and somehow final answer which
is maybe a tad disappointing is that you
will not get any progress for four
tensors even if you knew the best
possible lower bounds for three tenses
but any progress I may be jumping into
the dark side of the right side
depending upon who you are and ignoring
a constant so I'm just gonna give you a
flavor of the numbers without throwing
the general numbers at you so there's
some obvious lower bounce that you have
and the obvious lower bounds for three
tensors so when I say three tenses I
mean C and tends to see intensity and so
the dimension of each side will be n
there's an obvious lower bound of n okay
you can think about how you want to
prove this very easy and 4/4 time says
there's no obvious a lower bound of N
squared for five tensors also the only
love on the kind of obvious is our only
N squared and by reduction to matrix
rank you can essentially only prove such
lower bounds maybe with a bit of a
constant involved yeah so the barrier is
only allowed for maybe slightly big
constants but in fact we really don't
even know how to make that constant
better than two and if I have to say
precisely for let's say border rank I
don't even know how to make this N
squared so this guy N squared plus one
this is how bad we are now suppose I
loved you the reduction to three tenths
of I on linear maps well of course you
can prove with the best lower bounds
that are possible for three tensors but
for four tensors you can't do anything
better than N squared and this is
surprising to me but when you go to five
tenths as you get something slightly
better than N squared but still not as
good as the best possible lower ones so
with this let me tell you what this talk
is going to be about I'm not going to
explain a lot about how the numbers
exactly work out so the proof of the
barriers result that though we kind of
saw last talk of some parts of it is the
two parts that one is what I call
structure on algebraic and the other
part is what I call combinatorial yeah
so there many interesting problems on
the con metal siren when I say commit
all I mean this whole notion of taking
these homogeneous multi linear rank and
so on and you you have to run the
numbers you have to find you have to be
smart about how to pick the monomial
basis and there's many interesting
things there but I'm gonna focus on the
algebraic and structural part because
without this you the cognitive part
doesn't mean much and so now this part
is not so difficult in the case of
matrices but it gets harder in the more
general situation where he took the the
rank of all yeah I just get it yeah okay
so let me put the set up and set up is
you have a polynomial map from some
vector space into matrices and this
vector space you should think of as the
vector space that parameterize is the
simples given such a polynomial map you
can think of it as an N by n matrix
whose entries of polynomials
well I already told you it's a
parameterization and the hypothesis is
that whatever simple guy you have its
image is low rank all right so let's
just give that a number smaller and the
conclusion is somehow that you can write
it in this symbolic fashion so here the
Z 1 to Z M you think of as variables so
you're upgrading this generic behavior
or in this case you know I'd not even
seen the word generic yeah reading the
behavior at every point the symbolic
level but in doing so you have to go to
the power series so you can write it as
a sum of our rank one tenses but these
rank one tensors are defined over the
power series around some point okay and
this is the part where where Klem said
you can do it over the rational
functions and then he said you can
somehow forget about the denominators
and we all seem to agree yeah the
workaround for that is yes I will tell
you in a minute okay and you will end up
with power series denominator so this
strategy the proof comes in two steps
the first is you have this generic
behavior which is part of your
hypothesis is that you every point goes
into a low rank matrix and use that to
upgrade it to symbolic behavior by which
you say well the symbolic guy where you
plug in variables for these entries its
rank is going to be smaller than R over
the function field and this is a simple
argument using the fact that rank is
captured by miners suppose this guy's
rank was greater than R then there's
some R plus 1 by r plus 1 miner that
doesn't vanish so you evaluate this you
get some nonzero polynomial find some
value at which it's nonzero plug that
value back in and that guy would be
greater than R
so we get this kind of symbolic
decomposition and now you're over this
function field which is troublesome
because what do we do with denominators
and the point is you can you know kind
of clear denominators you can get them
all under the same denominator this is
fine and once you do that you can expand
this denominator as a power series
around some point not necessarily zero
but that's maybe not that big of an
issue you can expand it around some
point and then once you do that you get
this I mean you get the one that you get
this kind of expression and now you're
over the power series well you may be
over the power series but if you're
ranked as if your map had certain degree
degree M or degree K or something then
most of these terms are kind of
pointless you just know they will all
cancel out in the end so you can
restrict yourself to some finite amount
of data and then you do the combinatoric
s-- to get your bounds yeah you just you
can restrict yourself to a finite number
of monomials just as what Tim was doing
and you can do some comet arts and get
your mouse now I want to make this I
want to pull this up to a higher level
where we try to see what exactly is
required in this proof and how much more
general can we make this and what and
you run into trouble pretty quickly so I
want to think of this rank less equal
are matrices as an algebraic format and
this is a name that I just came up with
maybe three days ago so if you have
better names for it let me know I want
to say it's it's it's an algebraic
format because saying that matrix as a
set as rank less than or equal to R is
the same thing as saying you can write
it as a sum of our rank one matrices you
can write it in some algebraic form some
specified algebraic form
and now what the theorem say the result
that I that it just kind of described is
saying is generically let's forget the
word generic for the moment generically
if the image of this map L we plug in
points if it has a certain format this
particular format then so does the
symbolic guy yeah that's that's roughly
what it's saying is it true for more
general algebraic format can you always
upgrade this behavior on points to
symbolic behavior back yes yeah
absolutely
I love the question because I'm going to
address it right now okay so somehow if
you think about what this rank less
equal are matrices are they're captured
by the image of a polynomial map any
rank one matrix is vector times another
vector may be transposed and then as
some of these things say you can
parameterize these all by some big
vector space and the image of this is
the rank of all of rank less equal ah
matrices the image could be a space of
tensors polynomials whatever it is with
some structure and for example rank less
equality matrices are captured by this
particular map so CN tenses CN cross C
and says you take one vector another
vector u tensor them
that's a rank one matrix you do it D
times so you have D rank one matrices
and then add them out that's a
polynomial map from this guy to Makai
what are some other examples well sums
of rank want answers yeah this is why I
made to see is you can take tensors of
any size sums of powers of linear forms
this is like what in rank but maybe you
can do something more funny you can say
maybe a sum of odd things each one is a
product of a linear and a quadratic form
if you realize what I'm saying any
circuit any circuit so maybe another way
of calling this as a circuit whatever
language you like so I wondered I mean
this is maybe something I'm asking you
guys but is any polynomial map basically
a circuit that's what algebraic formats
at and i here's the general question
that I'm kind of trying address is so
this polymer so this map L was a
polynomial map yeah it may be important
for the application but not for the not
for the result as well yeah yeah what so
this is part of this talk is I'm asking
for more applications for this sort of a
result it's a little more generic I can
maybe abstract it out even more and say
reducible variety with whatever it is a
maybe let's not worry so much about all
of those things yes rational map will
work and I will eventually start saying
the word generic
so so we have this polynomial map and we
have this algebraic format which is also
polynomial map but I want but it has a
separate role so I will keep referring
to it as an algebraic format and the
hypothesis is that for most points and I
use the word generic if you don't like
the word generic you replace the word
generic with all and you don't lose
anything in the stock it's just too weak
a result if you want to follow generic
and you don't know what this is think
with probability 1 if you want it to be
more precise take a big sphere now this
is compact you can actually put a
uniform measure and take probability 1
and it's still
so the genetic guys the image of this
map for a generic point in here for most
points in here has a certain algebraic
format that's the hypothesis yeah just a
very simple hypothesis and the
conclusion is I'm going to upgrade this
the symbolic level but then here comes
the catch the catch is to do this to
upgrade this to symbolic level I have to
go to not the function field but I have
to go to the closure of the function
field
I mean square root of Z does it have a
power suppressor is may be difficult but
we have some kind of handle in it
everything is a solution to some
algebraic equation now if you remember
what we did in the matrices case we
wrote it as you know in terms of
rational functions had a common
denominator and we expanded out the
denominator and power series well we
have more trouble here we now have
algebraic functions and we have to
convert them to power series yeah this
is a maybe a little exercise in in a
thought exercise not not a next thing so
if you take a function like square root
of Z well you don't have a power series
expansion around 0 but if we took some
other point you could have a power
series expansion so that's okay but now
you have many of these guys so you could
have picked so you have two choices in
fact if you pick some other point if you
want to find a power C's expansion for
square root of zero and one you have two
choices
yeah one for which the value is one one
for which the value is minus one it's a
two to one function so you you know you
picked one of these power C's let's say
and then you come later on and suddenly
you find yourself with the fourth root
of Z for which you have four choices so
that's not good only two choices are
consistent with their first choice how
do you know you can make a consistent
choice
I have 132 functions how do you know
there exists a consistent tricep our
series
maybe think about it for a little bit
it's a I don't know if you can write
this out in a very very elementary way
as to why you can choose this
consistently but just think about what
can go wrong and what can't if you get
bored with everything else yeah but the
point is yes you can't replace them with
power series and I will give a
reasonable meaning to all of these
things it will be it will end up being
true for most points you won't be able
to do it over every point this this is
already the rational functions already
tells you why you can't do it for every
point but yeah for most points it would
work but we only need it around one
point if you want to do it for kind of
those applications so let me illustrate
the need for algebra closure you think
the obvious where the first replacement
that you can get as VI sub Z's just
coming from some closure of funky and
but it's some more work you can actually
get it to be a from the power series
ringing around the point but how Susy's
are now they're still multivariate is
that yes multivariate yeah yeah okay so
maybe I'm a little lazy and if I were
better I would have put an under
underline or an over line over the Z's
but every time I say a letter and not
people it just put an underline over
language of only like
so I'm going to Alaska late the need for
an algebraic closure with maybe doesn't
exactly fit in that setup but has the
same same reason so consider a 2 by 2
symbolic matrix for variables in there
now if you plug in generic values for
these then you should be able to
diagonalize it your diagonal matrix so
for most matrices the two eigenvalues
are going to be distinct so you will be
able to diagonalize but now whatever I
had to do it in a symbolic fashion I can
do it but I have to go to the closure
why do I have to go to the closure is
think about what the two eigenvalues are
the two eigenvalues are going to be
roots of the characteristic polynomial
you write out the characteristic
polynomial it's this T squared minus Z 1
plus Z 4 times T plus this determinant
expression which is Z 1 Z ok what are
the roots of this quadratic formula
throw it in there's a square root there
that obviously doesn't go away and so
you have no choice but to go to the
algebraic closure this is more or less
the same reason but you have to give a
proof ok I guess this is the point where
I'm done with the
I have the main statement written having
learnt a lesson from Anka that you can
write ahead of time so we have our setup
which is you have this map L which is a
polynomial map and you have this map
which is an algebraic format and the
hypothesis is that for most points the
image of L lies in the image of M
another way of saying it for most points
and the image of L has this algebraic
format and the conclusion is two parts
the first part is you can upgrade this
to symbolic level but you have to go to
the algebra closure and the second
conclusion as well will make will make
our life easier by running away from the
algebraic closure down to power series
okay so if you've had some experience
with yeah an application of the implicit
function yes this is a in some sense
this is exactly what I want to do but
somehow I don't seem to know how to
write the proof in complex analytic
language so there are generalized
versions of basic functions absolutely
you should be able to do this my
personal view is you should be will do
this completely in the world of complex
analysis but I have trouble writing it
down on the other hand I can replace the
complex numbers with any algebraically
closed field of characteristic zero and
the proof birth through which I don't
know if you can push a complex analytic
proof to that generality
this is this this is probably more my
inability to to understand complex
analysis then the non-existence of such
a proof in fact this is exactly what I
told people should first show up but
after months we didn't seem to have a
proof so here we go okay so if you know
something about schemes here's one way
you might think of this and you might
say well this is some scheme it has a
genetic behavior let's pass to the
genetic point and then interpret the
generic point concretely and this is
roughly what you will get but I will not
use this language so I am well I will
give you a simpler proof so you come up
with this proof this is very natural if
you've seen a lot of geometry going this
it looks very clear to to somebody who's
seen generic points and and how to do
this and it's very clear for you why you
have to get the algebraic closure here
okay so then I wrote this proof down and
alternately Avianca tobogganing why do
we have to go to schemes why is there no
elementary proof yeah so I I got to
sleep one day and I have a dream and in
this dream my advisor shows up hunt
ducks and I'm telling him look there is
this interesting result that I've sort
of come across this proof and I'm doing
this and I tell him look you have to go
to the algebraic closure and and he
looks at me he says well if you need the
algebraic closure it just must be no
still in such yeah so I wake up the next
day yes it is a real thing
and here is a proof that is based simply
on the nostril and size so first let me
start with this what does it mean to say
there exists the case of this last line
here what does it mean to say that
exists we want to be K such that L of
some point is M of some M of just be
want to be Kim what does this mean so
first let me just struck this out a bit
L is a function is a polynomial map from
cm to CN so it has n coordinates so I
write those coordinates as L 1 to L N
and similarly has n coordinates I would
write it as M 1 to MN and I will pick
variables T 1 2 TR are being uh this R
and what is it saying this is saying
each for each I ally of a is M I of B so
the I will write it again it means I am
one of t minus l1 of a equal to 0 all
the way up to M n of t minus Ln of a
equal to 0 this system of equations has
a solution that's what it means to say
there exist some point for which you
have this let's say is fixed for the
yeah so a is not really playing the role
at the moment just what does this
statement mean this statement means that
you have some kind of system of
equations which it has a solution and
well and now in this system of equations
I wanna say is a number Ln a face number
and these are polynomials in with
complex coefficients with variables in T
1 2 T R so now what does the statement
for generic these guys the generic a
there exist this means for generic a
this has a solution so generic
a the system of equations has a solution
and you want to upgrade this to the
symbolic level so in the symbolic level
I replaced the a with the Z and I'd like
to same equations out and I want a
solution but for some reason I want to
go out to the algebraic closure yeah
so why do I want to go to the algebraic
closure not Stirling starts yeah so I
assume the contradiction so if it
doesn't have a solution then I can write
a linear combination using polynomials
in this polynomial ring with
coefficients in K so that that sum is
equal to 1
you know that's a very deep result and
maybe not everybody who knows it also
understands how serious it is it
contains a lot of things so we have this
and now what do I want to do I want to
take this contradiction and push it back
down to the level where I forget about
the Z's and put them put numbers for
disease but here comes the problem these
P eyes are polynomials with coefficients
in this algebraic closure
if I could evaluate them at some point
then I just evaluate the whole thing at
a and I get a linear combination that's
equal to 1 how do I evaluate these guys
this is a problem and it's kind of the
same problem how do I evaluate them in a
consistent way you will have a square
root of Z a 4th root of Z you don't want
to put different values you want to make
sure there's consistent with hitting
them ok so let me leave this here
so let me look at what something bi
inside here looks like each such guy
looks like a sum that's why polynomial
looks like it has a bunch of
coefficients and a bunch of monomials
and these guys themselves are inside
this algebraic closure of the function
field so if I want to make sense of
evaluating PII I simply have to make
sense of evaluating P II's all of them
well where do they all live somehow if
you want if you think about it you want
something like a homomorphism which is
what consistency means from this guy
back to the complex numbers
that's what an evaluation is you have
things inside this algebraic closure and
this function field and you want to make
sense of what evaluating at a point is
that means you should be able to give
some way of assigning a number to each
one of these guys
I am glad Peter as telling my talk for
me ahead of what's gonna come yeah but
but here's the problem that you have no
Maps between these fields the only maps
between fields or injections in this
case of bigger feel than that well but
you think about it and you say well you
don't actually need all of them you only
need these guys and where do these guys
live they live inside some suffering
well what is the suffering
let's just take all the ones that you
want and I when I put this I mean all
eyes on ease all of it and so you want
like this but maybe we want something
more specific we want a map like this
that sends zi to AI yeah because if it
send zi to something else it might mess
up so let me see where I am
so maybe let me remark one thing maybe
it's very important maybe it's not so
he's easy to spot what the importance is
this is a finitely generated see algebra
this is what allows you to stay within
the world of algebraic geometry
it's kind of crucial but maybe we don't
see exactly why so you have this
injection from the polynomial ring into
this guy that I called R for the moment
another way that I'm want to think about
this is when I say I want to evaluate P
I at is I want to think of them as
functions that I can evaluate what is a
natural space on which these guys can
actually be evaluated and this is where
I have no not much choice but I want to
go to this guy called m-spec so this is
a funny thing where you say I tell you
what the functions are tell me what the
space is this is a problem that if
you're inside point-set topology you
don't have an answer for if I give you a
topological space you know if I give you
the functions in a topological space you
cannot recover the topological I'll give
you a functions on a manifold you cannot
recover the manifold I'll give you the
functions on an algebraic variety you
can recover the algebraic variety and
that process is m-spec okay this is also
another reason why algebraic geometry is
is very robust the functions give you
everything about the way the right
anyone so this gives a map on the
varieties and the variety corresponding
to this is just the complex plane
and now what the fact that this is an
injection will tell me that this map is
is dominant and so it contains a zariski
open set so let's maybe forget about
that for a minute but in any case now I
want to tell you something I wanna tell
you something that's a little bit of a
digression but I think something that we
should know what do I mean by am spec so
in this case I will pick some easy guy
and I will tell you tell you what I'm
spec means in my language and I've
already told you that the M spec is a C
to the M and there's a simple thing
right maybe if you've seen it before a
point here so M spec is a set of maximal
ideals and the maximal ideal that you go
to is something that looks like this
there's actually a third thing in here
which makes this very precise and more
robust and easier to understand is both
of these guys are the same thing as
homomorphisms from this ring down to the
complex numbers and what is the
homomorphism that corresponds to this is
you have a map PA
that sends zi2 AI and what is this way
this guy here is Colonel of the song of
martyr
yeah this is a sofa Soaker now I want
you to pick a point in the image of this
so let me say a isn't the image of
m-spec what does this mean this means
it's at this point in am Spock
want to interpret this as this
homomorphism what does it mean that it's
in the image it means there is some map
from art to see this is a point upstairs
then maps to this guy but what does maps
to this guy mean it means when you pull
back along this injection you should get
free of a free subway so if you do this
well but what is this mapping this map
here send Zi to a I say yeah before
morphism from art to see that extends
the map Zi going to airing now maybe
I'll stop here and say that makes
precise what I can do from P I to get to
numbers CI which is going to be what do
I want to call this I want to just call
this fee a of P I just apply the ring
homomorphism and you're good because and
the reason you wanted to extend Zi to AI
is because that will force a lie of Z to
go to a lie of a so that's the proof of
having to go to algebraic closure so
another thing that I see is as as the
days passed by people seem to get bolder
and bolder as to what what words they
can throw out and I have to get a little
more bold that to push this down to
power C so somehow I claimed this part
is done and I will
try to explain a bit about how to get to
power series from this and somebody
mentioned complex analysis and implicit
function theorem and I like this because
this is the motivation for all of these
guys so here's another thing that I want
you to notice this ring sits inside this
algebraic closure of the function field
and therefore its transcendence degree
is there for transcendence degrees M and
this transcendence degree happens to be
the dimension of the Associated variety
so the very fact that you can always
translate between functions and the
corresponding variety means you should
be able to tell me the dimension by just
looking at this ring and the way you do
that is to look at the transcendence
degree and it translates to the
dimension this dimension is M this
dimension is M what kind of a map is
this and my claim is I'm going to draw a
toy picture and you should process this
is kind of what cm looks like because I
can't draw M dimensions and this guy is
should also be M dimensional so it
should also look like a line but it's
going to look like many lines so it's
kind of looked like something funny
it might look something like this
and what what do I mean by this picture
this map should just be projection down
I claim you've all seen maps like this
if you forget about these okay so these
are holes that means it doesn't actually
come down to anything there's some
points missing the image that's possible
most points seem to have roughly the
same number of three images these are
maps that you might have seen before for
a let me give you an example of such a
map an example of such a map is you take
the circle to the circle and it takes Z
going to Z to the N so this is a map
where kind of the circle wraps around
itself n times and if I had to draw that
kind of a type picture for it I would
draw
that seemed to hit your intuition well
enough yeah that's the thing now the
only problem is okay so by the way what
would this correspond to this would
correspond to somehow guess I say Z to Z
to the N but if I took the coordinate
here as T then that would be T to the 1
over N and that's what allows you to so
T to the 1 over N is naturally a
function on that and there are n choices
for the preimage the only problem here
is maybe not everything has to be as
nice as that so what you might happen is
you might have some crashing of points
you might have some points that are not
really there but if you throw away some
bad points you will get something that
looks like that and I think the notion
for this is a covering map so it's
ramified cover if if you like that done
but what it really means is around most
points up here and down here are locally
the same yeah so these guys here are
locally the same now let me go back to
this point is making about algebraic
varieties and their corresponding
functions and then there's this point
about complex analysis throwing an
implicit function what are functions
around a small neighborhood this is
something we know what are functions
around a small neighborhood if you think
about complex analysis these are power
series
suctions around in some kind of
imprecise informal sense functions
around a small neighborhood of power
series which means functions around this
small neighborhood and the functions
around this small neighborhood are kind
of the same because they look you look
the same
functions are on this more neighborhood
of power series therefore you can
interpret them as functions around that
small neighborhood around that point
okay great but on the other hand we said
this is a variety on which these guys
are naturally functions therefore you
can also interpret these guys as
functions on a small neighborhood if
it's a function on the big thing you can
interpret them as functions on a small
neighborhood and therefore you can
interpret them as functions and as power
series why are this matter okay so let
me see if I really want to say something
I don't know these are series are
difficult so series are you throw you
throw in an extra level of difficulty
right nice you have nth roots and power
series and the series is bigger than
what we need zero series is the
algebraic closure of the power series
when we try to not cover you know even
further away but here is the argument
they argument to somehow that and I
don't really know how to simplify it and
again this is part of maybe my inability
to understand exactly why things like
this a true is so you have this map
m-spec are 2 cm and i gave you this
little picture that said it's you know
it's almost like a covering map it's a
locally and isomorphism one most points
except some bad points such my
perspective
and okay so one thing you know is that
you're in characteristic zero and this
complex numbers is an algebraically
closed field so what this means is this
means and moreover you have the same
dimension so okay so first thing this
will tell you that your map is
generically smooth this is apparently
something that we should know from real
analysis perspective this is like Sarge
theorem the set of critical points is a
measure zero this is the analog of that
that says most most at most points the
maps going to be smooth and you have
that the relative dimension is 0 that
means the both of the same dimension
because this is dimension m and this is
a dimension so at this point I was
hoping Peter will get up and tell me
that this to imply generically it all
what this means is that this map is a
locally an isomorphism at most points
that's exactly what the terminology here
means yeah so for generic you know so
for most points you have some point
upstairs which is locally isomorphic to
the point downstairs and now you can
interpret them as power series and this
is also formal because generically at
our means so how do you interpret power
series is from the algebraic geometry
perspective is you take what's called
the completion of the local ring and
then map on the completion of local
rings is an isomorphism the completion
of the local ring downstairs is power
series and therefore you conduct I will
with that say this is also kind of
concluded
but what I'm really asking for is what
else can we use this for so how I look
at these these talks by me Rajan Chandan
and so on and the top of a
reconstruction and they seem to fit in
here but I don't seem to know what they
say the big function of the power series
you look for a point where the Jacobian
of the defining equation is nonzero and
it is large enough credit test
laughing a factor second one yeah the
only problem is you okay here here's a
problem you know up a lot of care to
stick to precisely what you say but the
only thing you can't do is I don't know
how to write a power series for this
as long as you run away from things like
this it feels like you can try to do too
directly without doing what are the
Jacobian is identically zero
you look at the if you're large enough
characteristic I agreed we'll have yeah
that's right
if you large enough factors to kick into
this zeros zeros considered infinity in
terms of large enough that your service
is specifically for zero characteristic
right yeah but I the same argument sort
of works and this is your guess it's
over so here we only need like take you
don't actually need the closure right
you only need something like say
n-dimensional extension so instead of
using apart cities can't be throwing any
more variable like say you throw in more
variables Y I so that by any satisfy
going like if you had a square root of Z
1 plus Z for its mean why I said that y
squared is even 34 so you have other
constraints but instead of are
suggesting working with polynomials but
you want to come back to the original
variables right you can do this I mean
this is the same same thing where I say
these guys haven't part of this ring and
you're saying you want to write this
ring out as generators and relations so
that's where we are but some of the
applications we want to come back to the
original variable see
can you explain why concluding that this
is about cities at some point it's
efficient to get something like your
commentary about yeah so what happens is
you know these guys here so the simples
and the Swiss map will have a certain
degree there will be a homogeneous map
of a certain degree and you will have
this equality where on this side you
have it in terms of power series but on
the left side you only have polynomials
to a certain degree so even though you
have power series here the relevant
monomials are kind of bounded this is
all around one point but this isn't a
completely purely algebraic form right
yeah so once you come down to this and
you have power series on one side and
polynomials on the other side you can
forget about what these functions mean
you can forget about everything and look
at it from a purely algebraic point of
view you have two power series power
polynomials lots of power series so two
power series they're equal on the one
side there are certain monomials of
certain small degree and the other side
you can have large monomials but you
know they have to cancel out so you can
sort of ignore a lot of them and only a
few of them really matter
the beginning you said like you have a
optimal three order tensor lower bounds
and probably nothing before I feel like
I'm just well you have to do this with
what Kim was saying the so this is the
algebraic on part and then you have the
combinatorial part where you have to do
the same kind of work that Clem does for
burial
ranked methods to matrix rank so there's
additional work to be done but that
additional work begins from from the
spouses of tens of products of two
things which give you an one matrix will
ever tell the product of three things
immediately return so they mentioned
mostly over an optimal bounce yes well
so you get instead of thank me so again
[Applause]